le grand retour du rendez vous annuel de
la porte de versailles la 103,30 103e
édition de la foire de paris a ouvert
ses portes ce matin et les inventions
déroutante utiles ou futiles
vous allez le voir ne manquent pas
françois jullien pieds-noirs et ligne à
roussel oui allez voici un t-shirt aulas
sur l'offre oiseaux bien ils sont prêts
à vendre père et mère pour vous
refourguer leurs inventions et ils sont
3000 comme ça sur la fois d'envoyer la
vapeur dans la table là vous allez
tendre votre linge et là vous allez
repensé avec les mains on va mais le
grand prix d'innovation cette année
revient à se lave vaisselle avec deux
blocs indépendant pour laver le
nécessaire elle avait un seul espace
aura besoin d'environ 2 9 kg et marie à
14 15 litres pour une charge peu calme
pendant la vie très traditionnel
et pour les amateurs de vins rien n'est
trop beau pour conserver un bordeaux
cave à vin télécommande et 12000 euros
la grosse innovation c'est que vous êtes
à mettons dans votre salon vous avez la
cave au sous sol
mais vous avez toujours la visibilité
directement sur les températures et les
températures montent sur la foire car
entre de cuisine et une baignoire les
sex-toys jouets sexuels ont trouvé leur
place
cette fois pas de démonstration imaginez
vous même le concept mais pourquoi la
foire s'encanaille tél parce que c'est
dans l'air du temps parce qu'on en parle
partout on en parle dans les magazines
féminins on en parle à la télé on
commence en parle un petit peu partout
parce que ça se démocratise
est ce qu'on parle du plaisir de la
femme mais les inventions les plus sexy
comme on dit ou les plus folles c'est au
concours lépine qu'on les trous ici fini
les crottes de chiens sur les trottoirs
avec cette invention quatre pattes fait
ses besoins dans le salon le mal la
paroi verticale la chaîne dans le baht
levin et collectés dans les tiroirs que
l'on vide dans les toilettes et cet
inventeur excité lui a trouvé une
alternative aux barbelés pour protéger
sa propriété
j'essayais de passer ben je peux pas
terminer c'est impossible je vois pas
passer la main je peux pas pourquoi pas
celle à la je prends une corde
j'arrive à auch peut pas aller plus loin
je me retrouvais en france de ce faire
bon mais ne leur dites pas qu'ils sont
fous ces inventeurs car certains ont
révolutionné notre quotidien
on leur doit notamment le fer à repasser
à vapeur ou la machine à laver le linge